movies we all love them we all watch
them and sometimes they change our lives
mostly they don't but sometimes they do
and here are some of the ones that did
for me
number one spider-man it's not a perfect
film it's not even the best spider-man
film but when I saw it was the first
time that I ever experienced
spider-man's origin story and it was
that which cemented him as being my
favorite superhero as a kid I loved
spider-man because he was just really
cool and I spent literally years of my
life fantasizing about having all of his
powers pretty standard really as I grew
up however I realized that the reason I
liked spider-man so much was because he
was just the most relatable superhero
for me he's given this great power that
he doesn't ask for he instantly goes out
and uses that power for personal gain
there's only after his arrogance catches
up with him that he then decides to go
and use his power for good
maybe it's weird for me to relate to the
character so much but I never felt like
I asked to be Charlie is so cool like
it's just something that kind of
happened to me and now that it is Who I
am
I do feel a responsibility to try and
use that for good as opposed to just
using it for myself and of all people
Spiderman was the one who taught me that
number two jirô Dreams of Sushi so this
is a documentary about an 85 year old
sushi chef called Jiro
that my friend Nicola told me to watch
because he felt like Jiro the 85 year
old sushi chef reminded him of me and I
don't even like sushi so obviously I was
intrigued I really love this film but I
was simultaneously flattered and a bit
worried the Jiro reminded McClure of me
flattered because Jiro's crazy
dedication to sushi has made him
arguably the best in the world at what
he does I don't think I deserve it but
yes I am happy to be compared to that
but it scared me because while Jiro does
seem to be happy it's hard to really
know if he feels fulfilled by the life
that he's led and he also seems to have
some pretty serious regrets about not
being close to his family because of his
dedication to his work I always thought
that I wanted to be the kind of person
who would work and work and work and
work at one particular thing and become
the best that I could at that one thing
and I still kind of do want that but at
the same time this film reminded me not
to work so hard that I forget to live as
well number three Toy Story 3 I'm pretty
sure that the original Toy Story was my
first ever favorite film I have good
memories of sitting right here in this
very spot actually watching it over and
over and over again on VHS I remember
acting it out with my little brother in
front of the television and obviously I
got my own buzz lightyear for Christmas
too then twelve years passed and I see a
trailer for this film called wall-e
which I initially dismiss is just being
another animated film for kids but then
I see in the cinema I fall in love with
it completely in love of it I go home I
look up Pixar the people who made the
film I discover they're the same people
who made Toy Story my mind is blown and
instantly I'm a Pixar fanboy again two
more years pass and I find myself at
Pixar studios about to see a preview
screening of Toy Story 3 before the film
is even finished and then after
introducing it the director of the film
Lee Unkrich
turns around and says hey Charlie my
kids love your videos I don't know if I
really learn any lessons from the whole
thing other than that just sometimes
things can come full circle in ways that
you do not expect them to and when they
do it can be unbelievably cool number 4
Kiki's Delivery Service so a teenage boy
related to spider-man maybe that's not
much of a leap but finding myself at 20
years old relating very heavily to a 13
year old animated witch with a talking
cat was slightly more unexpected for me
mild spoilers in the film Kiki who loves
to fly on herbarium leaves home and sets
up a delivery service and so the thing
that she loves flying becomes her job as
a result this Kiki then finds herself
losing her ability to fly and it's only
through an effort to try and get her
powers back that she realizes she has to
find a new purpose in order to be able
to fly again basically the film is a
perfect analogy for writer's block and
for what it's like to lose your passion
for something that you used to love I'm
a massive fan of Studio Ghibli's films
if you haven't heard of them they are
basically the Japanese equivalent of
Disney and Kiki's always been my
favorite film others simply because of
that lesson it taught me about
creativity which it taught me at a time
when I really needed to hear it and when
nobody in real life seemed to be giving
me the answer I was looking for I had to
find it in a movie number five sure of
the dead every single film that I have
ever watched has in some way contributed
to me wanting to be a filmmaker but if I
had to pick one that tipped me over the
edge it would undoubtedly be Shaun of
the Dead this might not come as a
massive surprise given that like Shaun
of the Dead every film I've made so far
has been a low-budget British comedy
that plays off of a bigger genre and
given the Edgar rights movies are a
massive influence on many aspiring
filmmakers my age almost to the point of
cliche but can't deny way influences
just cuz there
same as everyone else's it's such a
brilliant film it is so well written and
well shot but the key for me was that it
was those things while simultaneously
being low-budget and British and it was
thinking about those things that made me
realize that filmmaking is a real-life
thing that I can actually do if I wanted
to and now I am so yay that's my list
thanks for watching goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool
thank you for watching here's my most
recent video in case you missed it I was
inspired to make this video after seeing
Nicolas videos on this topic and he in
turn was inspired by John D Parker so do
check out their videos as well and if
you'd like to do your own personally
significant films then feel free to
you're allowed it's your life do what
you wish but don't murder or all of the
other illegal things but you can you can
make video responses they can't even do
that anymore can you guess just don't do
anything then
you